[Music]
Fran is on the line in Harrisburg
Pennsylvania hi Fran welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show hi thank you
I have a question a little nervous okay
my son is in its early 20s okay he's 21
anyway he was going to college he didn't
finish
that's just another story but I am on
baby step two and I know one of the
later steps is like to save money for
college but for me it kind of seems like
it's after like you know I mean like
he's already grown he's already an adult
do I owe him like you know the money I
should have saved no okay or is he like
totally responsible for his own college
or do I have any responsibility in that
what was your deal with him when he went
to college and got the student loan did
you say I'll pay it nope then he pays it
he signed up for it he's a big boy okay
he's like a grown man okay I want him to
go to college I still kinda didn't go to
call quitter he got thrown out or
whatever happened right that's not I
mean that wasn't your decision you
didn't cause it
so I don't know it wasn't cause you
didn't pay for it that he quit right no
not at all okay okay
how much student loan debt does jr. have
about 3,000 4,000 something like that
what's he doing for a living right now
he's working at fast food so he's living
with you what living with you he's 21
yes so what's he gonna do with his life
that's an area of contention there yeah
okay I think he can do better
I've told him that you know he's not
really totally sure that direction he
wants to take yeah I can tell
I think he needs a direction and it
might be just out of your house
okay so that because nothing what I hear
is a listless kid that's adrift that's
kind of hanging out mommy still making
him dinner and he's partying at night
and making just enough to pay for the
party well not really I am I made him
totally responsible for his own food
oh I don't pay for his food okay any of
it okay yeah now last year I gave him a
choice either you give me to get a job
or like your choice is either go to
school full-time work full-time for do
half and half there you go like you I
mean and I gave him a deadline and he
got the job like right at the deadline
so he's got a full-time job in fast food
yeah I know there's such a thing it's
it's a full-time yeah time they don't
need people 25 hours is not full-time
okay 40 hours is full-time right I told
him that too I told him to ask for more
hours and you know he realizes he needs
more money he doesn't want to work in
computers somehow but he's not sure in
what way
good well that's good we found something
that he's excited about and aimed at
let's uh let's start that because really
what's happening now is not you know the
30-year old version of this kid is still
living with you if he doesn't if he
doesn't change his direction I know see
part of it is that I don't think he
wants any more loans because he's now
knows about the plan yeah okay okay and
so he's trying to save money for his
emergency fund
yeah are you married no okay are you in
a good church yeah okay I want you to
grab a couple of 40 year old 30 year old
successful business guys men in your
church and have them take this kid to
lunch okay and boxes ears okay okay
because I'm not because what
happening you're doing a really good job
of mothering him and he needs a guy to
bust him yeah it's like it's too
comfortable yeah like I'm not well
here's the thing here's the thing okay
he's just kind of he's just kind of
wishy-washy it's just like I'll get a
job because my mommy made me it sounds
like he's 16 you know and what am I
gonna do a mobile operators a week and
I'm gonna call that okay and nothing
okay about that so what he needs to be
doing is mowing grass or blowing leaves
or walking dogs I'm making $20 an hour
and working 80 hours a week and pay off
the $3,000 and save up the money to go
to tech school and get you know get a
degree in programming and go to code
school and learn how to be a programmer
he's get his little buddies get his
little button gear mm-hmm that's what he
used to do and then the $30,000 isn't
going to come up so I wanted me this kid
definitely needs to pay there's $30,000
it's gonna be good for his manhood okay
and but I'm a lot more worried about
getting him on track as a young man and
game quit acting like a little boy you
following me I'm not being insulting I'm
just being very clear I understand that
I'm like I don't want to kick him out
I'm his mom no I don't want you to kick
him out but I want him to have more
vision for his life than he has he
doesn't have a vision okay
he found his vision is limited he's he's
thinking about Friday that's why I was
accusing her partying a partier yeah
okay that's the lack of these are the
lack of his vision is what made me say
that that's what made me guess that okay
right no he'd rather than a couch and
play video games oh okay all right
you guys getting those little wire
cutters just cut those wires on that
thing and you know cut cut those a
disconnect that whole thing and just oh
okay now we're back to the real world
because Mario Kart is not is not pasta
not a possible job so we got to find
something else to do and so that's
what's happening he's getting sucked
into that and it's shutting his brain
down so we want a vision for his life I
want him to you know be willing to clean
out septic tanks because he can make 50
bucks an hour
with a toothbrush okay because that gets
him to where he can go to school and be
a programmer he never has to clean
septic tanks with a toothbrush again you
pay a price to win when you have a
vision for your life okay and that's
that's what I want that's what I want
for him that's what you want for him to
and that's why I'm thinking if you can
get some guys around him that are
successful he might it might rub off on
him a little bit and they might actually
mentor him a little bit and you know
love him enough to go dude unplug the
Gameboy seriously mmm-hmm
you know it's killing you you live in
your mother's house come on be a man
let's go and some of the guys coming
around him would love him and just say
love him enough to tell him the truth
you guys and and he'll let's help him
get and be because God has something a
lot more for him than flopping whoppers
and playing Nintendo and that's what I
want for him and that's what you want
for him and then the $3,000 thing is
going to be solved as a natural
byproduct of him having a vision for his
life again or for the first time ever
maybe and sometimes that involves a
little bit of bluntness or a lot of
bluntness and that's why I'm saying get
some guys around you and around him to
help him walk this out because sometimes
young men don't hear they hear better
from other men sometimes it's like if
you had a dog it's like if I was talking
to a dad who had a daughter and she was
I might get some ladies around her it's
not you know just to say this is let's
get you going here kiddo you got let's
have a vision for your life wear more
clothes do this right you know you can
do this and you can win you can be a
lady and you can be powerful and you can
be confident in the marketplace and you
can get stuff done and you need powerful
and confident ladies surrounds you to
tell you you can do that sometimes and
so you know it's you become who you hang
around with right kind of a thing so
yeah let's put a couple mentors in his
life and ask him to speak into his life
they'll do it they'll be happy to do it